oh man by now you probably heard about
this Taylor Swift
Scooter Braun drama a lot hasn't folded
so I'm just gonna break down every
single detail for you it's all started
when Taylor posted this to tumblr
basically expressing her anger that
scooter had purchased big machine for
three hundred million dollars scooter
reps or repped it's kind of unclear but
this is important Kanye West who Taylor
has had issues with in the past she even
says quote anytime Scott Borchetta has
heard the word Scooter Braun escaped my
lips it was when I was either crying or
trying not to he knew what he was doing
they both did
she also accuses scooter of incessant
manipulative bullying for years
scooter did rep Kanye when he released
famous Taylor my six I made famous now
Taylor says she was given the
opportunity to earn one album back at a
time for every new one she turned in
which in looking into it further meant
it be about a decade until she earned
them all back and big machine would
still have rights but more on that in
just a few after Taylor's post justin
bieber chimed in with a long statement
which started as an apology for bullying
her but then defended scooters character
and told Taylor she was crossing a line
as you know Justin and scooter go way
way back scooter is basically
responsible for Justin's career after
that it was an all-out bloodbath of
statements and celebrities picking sides
okay I'm gonna keep this part quick
mostly because I want to dive into Scott
Borchetta statement first of all todrick
Hall Taylor's BFF came to her defense he
used to be raped by scooter and called
him an evil person
only concerned with wealth listen to
these CDs of sick beats
but you should read the fine print on
the contract Hooters partner Allison
case ed todrick statements weren't
accurate but todrick came back with
receipts Cara Delevingne also weighed in
on Justin's post slamming both him and
his wife Haley so yeah she's team Taylor
Palsy Katy Perry Rihanna hi Martha hunt
also all supposedly team Taylor scooters
wife Yael shared this statement slamming
Taylor Demi lavato posted this totally
team scooter fYI Demi is scooters newest
client so there's that while celebs were
getting involved Scott Borchetta who
owns big machine shared his side of the
story he says he gave Taylor a heads-up
courtesy around 9:00 p.m. the night
before news of the sale broke but if she
were in London that would be about three
a and her time so like Taylor initially
said she probably did wake up to the
news he also says Taylor's dad is a
shareholder in big machine and that
there was a call all shareholders were
on to discuss the sale though Taylor's
rep tells et he actually opted out of
the call so he wouldn't have to keep
private info from Taylor Scott Borchetta
also shared this screenshot of the
contract they were working on in 2018 we
had a legal expert take a look and it
seems Taylor claiming she would have to
earn back her albums is accurate and it
looks like Taylor was okay with an
earned back deal for seven years but big
machine wanted to lock her in with ten
years and they would still have final
jurisdiction over everything big machine
would also get to license her new
materials also important to know in
Taylor's new deal with Republic Records
she was able to fight for herself and
other Republic artists to get more
return on streaming Taylor does
basically have full control now I
wouldn't want to do this if I didn't
have a hundred percent control I
wouldn't want to do this if it was up to
somebody else so yeah a lot to unpack
here and I'm sure more news on this
story is to come so be sure to keep it
locked to ET for all the latest until
next time I'm Katie Krauss and
now
[Applause]
[Music]